What's your deal if a guy goes out with
you they last you say about three months
what is it about what do guys do wrong
no I don't know I think what tires me
what turns me off is
easy when you when you get to this point
of being an artist it's too easy for
people to get interested on us and the
things that we have and then when I feel
like people just don't don't look at you
and just look at the things that you
have and the things that you are and
accomplished it it kind of sucks so in
other words it's hard for you to find
someone who can convince you that
they're there for you and not the things
that you have and the fame that you have
yeah maybe that also and maybe I don't
know it's just I don't know how to
explain it's just a thing and now I'm
being more selective are you in love no
I'm not have you ever been in love oh
yes
many times many times and yet still the
three-month rule no but nowadays I'm so
different like I swear I swear what
change therapy
therapy the me turning 30 changed
everything it's crazy it was kind of a
flip women still on the table you said
you're bisexual
yes I haven't been with a woman in in a
while
but can you fall in love with a woman
could you fall in love with a woman I
don't know why but no I don't think it
would fall in love with a woman it's
just kind of a fun thing once in a while
yeah but I wouldn't say no I don't I
never I wouldn't say never so now you're
looking for a soul mate this is a whole
new um
first of all I'm loving to be alone
ah really I'm loving okay
to be alone because I don't I I rather
have a relationship than being single
but I don't like wasting my time anymore
I used to waste my time a lot now I just
think I rather stay alone good quality
time with myself
than spend time hanging out with
whatever people
thank you